hi everyone I'm a little Charles on and
today I'm going to be teaching you guys
how to build it your first magic the
gathering deck I have here a board of
the Gods into a pack and a board of the
Gods fat pack huge thanks to Hasbro for
giving me these and this is what I'm
going to making a deck out of so usually
if you're making your own deck you can
have a lot more cards but I'm going to
do the best with what I have here I do
also have some cards to give away to you
guys so stay tuned until the end if you
want to find out how you can win some
stuff so there are five colors in the
magic together in universes white blue
black red and green and the first thing
you're going to want to do is separate a
deck into those colored I personally
play with just black but a lot of people
will prefer a decks that have two
separate colors the colors represent
strategies white is order protection and
light blue is knowledge manipulation and
illusion black which is what I play is
darkness ambition and death red is
freedom emotion and impulse and green is
growth instinct and nature so you're
going to want to separate your cards
into these colors so that it's really
easy for you to put them together or
pick the two or one or three even colors
that you want to put in your deck so the
reason I say one or two is because you
really need to narrow it down to know
exactly what you're going to play and
what strategies to go with sometimes two
colors work best because one color
cancels out the other colors weakness I
usually go with one because that's the
hardest way to run out of mana and
usually everything is really accessible
from the start but I'll get to that
later so now that you've got your deck
separate into colors it's time to choose
the colors that you want I said before
these depend on different strategies and
I find the best way for beginners is
just to pick a color their favorite
color even and decide if they want to
play with that or not have a few tests
around see which ones you like which
ones you don't like and then pick one or
two if you had some artifacts combine
them with the color that you've picked
next you need to separate cards
depending on their mana very that's the
number of symbols on the top right of
the card cards that aren't artifacts
will usually have a number and then two
symbols you add these all together so
the war chanter of Mogis has three and
then two skulls that means it's a five
you'll then come across things called
basic lands ru swamps because I'm a
black player separate these as well
lenz are very important so the way the
nervous system
cards works is that if a card has three
and a skull for example it's worth four
swamps you need to have four swamps on
the field to actually be able to summon
that card so the reason that you
separated your cards into numbers is
because obviously as you start playing
you will have a limited amount of swamps
meaning the cards you can summon will be
available matter value I guard for
example is worth one skull which means
that I would be able to play that on the
very first turn of any game much miss
title is a seven sometimes I may not
ever be able to get to a seven a game
could be over before that so the idea
here is that you want to have more ones
in your cards than sevens you also want
to have a deck of roughly 60 cards so
what I would normally do here is go
through the highest number and decide
which cards I really really want to keep
and get rid of everything that I don't
really really want as I get close to the
one I'll be more lenient and allow
myself to have more cards with the low
amount of value you can only have four
copies of any one card in your deck at
any one time
once you've separated all your cards
into piles and you've gotten rid of all
the cards you don't care about pick up
your cards and count how many you have
left over I ended up with twenty cards
and like I said before morester should
be about sixty because I only had twenty
I'm only going to add thirty lands what
I'm left with is a black deck with fifty
cards with mostly man on one cost but I
still have some sevens in there in case
the manor gets that by now this is the
most simple way to make a deck there are
far more complicated ways you can do it
this is probably just the best way for a
beginner to figure out that deck and
start playing the cards and figuring out
what they like and what they don't like
so hopefully that helps some of you out
I'm not sure if it's the right way to do
it but it's the way that echo is done it
and when you have more cards it works a
lot better but I tend to win a lot of
game so I feel like I'm doing something
right but now I have a holiday pack and
two throws intro packs to give you guys
unfortunately this one's only open to
Australian residents because shipping is
kind of expensive but for your chance to
win I want you to tell me what color you
do play as or what color you would play
as if you started playing magic
gathering and why the most
heads will win and competition will
close a week after I've posted this I'll
send the winners a message on YouTube so
hopefully you guys check your inboxes so
I can get your address and send you out
some grease I'll see you guys next time
bye